[Music]
welcome we're welcome back to the
podcast got a great guest for you guys
today the great Eduardo Garcia
thank you no no he's got an incredible
tale of overcoming adversity and really
a journey to wholeness that I think is
gonna really impact all of you guys so
I'm honored to be able to be a steward a
cipher for his story today what we
talked about thank you yeah we what we
discussed how I ended up with a
prosthetic limb joking sort of who I was
prior to that then going through this
the making of a documentary about the
worst day of your life I mean just
nothing big really just a small thing
we're gonna chronicle your life for
three years and then how that empowers
not just myself but you others to take
someone else's story and roll with it
you know make it investing attempted use
that's well said so get ready for the
next two hours you guys are gonna enjoy
it so thanks for joining us today and
enjoy my conversation with Eduardo
Garcia Eduardo man so nice to meet you
thanks for coming out at Calabasas great
to meet you we were talking before the
podcast I've been wanting to meet you
for a long time man so it is a pleasure
to have you in the studio it's my
pleasure likewise honored to be here and
really looking forward to it cool so you
were actually born in Calabasas yeah do
you remember or were you really young
when you moved to Montana I mean that's
what they tell me right yeah how many of
our memories are formed by our true
memory or by our sort of created memory
through repetition and storytelling and
you know whatnot but what I can't tell
you is you know I remember frying eggs
on the sidewalk when it was like
hundred-plus you know and I did not do
that in Montana much happening there no
I remember I mean there's photos that
prove it you know OshKosh B'gosh
overalls somewhere on an ocean you know
like so yeah we was the sea in this area
until 86 to 86 so your your and your mom
was like super into like a spiritual
community right that was like she didn't
know and that's
move to Montana but that started here
yeah there's a there was a spiritual
community called Church Universal and
triumphant that was founded in Pasadena
and had their campus or their you know
community headquarters in Pasadena and
in the mid to early 80s bought property
in Montana and you know so yeah
everybody made the mass mass movement
like everything in the vehicles drove
north to largely this ranch property
that was right on the northern border of
Yellowstone National Park Wow is she
still part of that community very much
so
and you weren't you grew up in it I grew
up in it yeah and what was the kind of
theological bent mm-hmm it's um it was
like an all-purpose seasonings for
spirituality in visiting I have to speak
in chef metaphors right but like if you
took this how I described it because how
many times in my life have I had friends
coming from the conventional or Catholic
or Christian or you know route and being
like so Edie
what kind of crazy like commune or
compound or cold like you know and so I
mean when I was a kid I defended it like
you know hey f you man yo like you don't
say that you don't talk about me and my
family like that and then at some point
I started to question like well what is
this anyway
and and so what I would I could say to
summarize is that I believe the church
Universal and triumphant to be a a
compilation of the world's religions so
grow up knowing who mother Mary was and
who Jesus was and also reading the
Ramayana books while we ate chicken soup
you know what I mean like on a Saturday
night and and my mom being of Jewish
descent so studying the Kabbalah and you
know you factor in all world's religions
all that the Bhagavad Gita the Quran
absolutely humble I uh spiritual
jambalaya yeah listening to BA Hons all
my buddies were like listening to Bon
Jovi like wow hey we were there we were
the kids bringing like tempeh you know
burgers to public school lunch right
super hippie everyone yeah I never ones
like trading their lunches at you nobody
wants to [ __ ] trade
right right a priest son and you know
whatever did you uh have you watched
wild wild country yet I haven't been
told I need to yeah I mean it's
impossible to have this conversation
without me thinking about that you know
obviously you know what you're talking
about is different but the idea of like
a spiritual community kind of moving
West and creating like they create it's
crazy you got to watch it yeah it's
super compelling but anyway man that's
wild so so now you're here and let's get
into the meat of this because you know
look at your a look at your arm I want
to hear this story
do you get tired of telling it yeah
there was a period so it was a period
right after my injury where it's not
that you tire of it it's you question
why you're doing it just like you
question why are you telling the story
yeah you know it's very rare I find
myself tired of doing something you know
I think that's like an easy out and so
what is what is your why behind that
yeah answer why you tell the story yeah
so at some point you know where I tired
telling retelling the story was is this
still serving everyone including me like
there's a certain amount of our time
here that I think we give to others but
we have to always give to ourselves I
mean like I just saying this makes me
grin while I'm talking to you because
I'm just on the right up here I'm
thinking all right and I've talked to my
fiancee today like honey we need to
focus on the [ __ ] that makes us happy
that brings out our best bits just say
no to that gig and I'm gonna say no to
this gear whatever you know and so for
for telling this story I will share my
experience for as long as I'm on this
earth as I believe it brings value to
others and elevates my own like healing
and continued education and being you
know right by treatment I think that
that what I like about that answer is
the kind of commitment to continually
healing and growing because I think it
would be easy to just kind of stay in
one place like I'm the guy with this and
this is how I define myself and
it becomes an all-consuming you know
identity for yourself rather than a part
of your story yeah that has value for
others and informs kind of how you make
decisions and live your life going
forward but isn't the end of this story
that's right right that's right and I
feel like we're getting I may be getting
ahead of myself for some listeners but
the easy one here that's at that point
is like at the end of the day it has to
check out with me like whatever the
action is whatever the story I'm telling
if I'm gonna go on Good Morning America
to talk about how my hand blew off
whatever it is it has to it has to gel
it has to make sense to Eduardo
otherwise and that's what I found at
some point I was like I'm not doing any
more interviews where I don't have a
certain degree of control in the
finished product because it's not what I
want to be a part of another article
going out talking about how I did XY and
Z which may not be true like I want to
be a part of it if I'm gonna be
interviewed I want to be working with
you to create the best piece of content
not working to just feel like some hype
and a page you know mm-hmm
we're gonna get into this story but but
I feel like it's it's still a good time
to ask you like you know what is it that
that you want people to take away from
your story like what is it that you want
them to walk away with that they can use
to impact their own lives in a positive
way yeah quite simply it is - it is the
to push for the understanding that
everything that comes across our
doorstep anything that comes through our
wheelhouse on any given day can be used
to impact your life to any end so it can
be negative it could be positive you get
to choose you get to work with it and
that is that is my take away is it's
it's not about being called the bionic
chef and being an amputee and all these
things it's
that happened but that's no different
than someone else's this or that
happening it's what we do with it it's
it's and and staying true to your
convictions
to true to your beliefs from that you
know yeah it's about your relationship
to obstacles and rather it and failure
and whatever gets thrown in your path
and rather than just looking at it from
the perspective of anything from
victimhood to annoyance to understand
like these are opportunities for your
personal evolution and growth which is
easier said than done
that's this that's I mean that's why I'm
here today you know is is for me this is
an opportunity to have sort of a
no-bullshit I mean that's how I want
this to be a no-bullshit sort of
conversation that reminds me of where
I've been who I am like what I'm doing
and where I'm going and sometimes it's
it's I mean I have been there where I
look I'll catch myself in a moment
where I need to awed it like immediately
like quick and like wait a minute I'm
still working on this two-year-old
vision just or this one-year-old vision
of Who I am or who I'm supposed to be
then it's like no no no not so I mean
that's the takeaway if I was a wrap it
up for everybody is wake up every
morning empowered by where you've been
and encouraged with the curiosity and
the Wonder lust and the possibility of
where you're about to go in that day
short term can be so impactful and super
super powerful and so just focus on that
you know do not be dragged down by
however many years you've had behind you
it's so hard you know we get in our
growth like I love what I do
but even reflecting back on how I've
lived my life the last three or four
days like I've just been in a work
groove you know I feel like you know
it's so easy to just like carve that
line and you stay in it and it becomes
wrote it becomes routine it becomes
easier to repeat and it becomes there's
more and more resistance it becomes more
and more difficult to just stop and like
be present and connect with gratitude
and
and wonder and all these childlike
qualities that that when I think of your
story and in watching the movie and all
of that like that seems to be that's
really like you know the beauty in what
you have to share thank you
so I don't know man I thought you know
yeah I appreciate I've been working like
around the clock the last couple days
and it's like and that and then watching
your movie and I'm like man you know I
need to I need to hit pause in my own
life you know that we all we yeah we I
think it there's no negative there man
no negative yeah yeah so let's so let's
uh let's walk backwards and talk a
little bit about where you came from
yeah short long as it relates to this
just yeah I mean so you grew up in
Montana I mean you're outdoorsmen from
the get-go yeah a little bit of a
hyperactive kid yeah some scruffs in
school uh yeah I mean the beyond that
that's I don't know if it has moving to
Montana at the age of six in 1987 was
like a dream come true for a kid that
didn't know he was dreaming about it
right like it just like where am i you
know
there's wild animals and there's Mother
Nature just whether I knew it or not
between the ages of 0 and 6 is my beacon
is my muse and so children are showing
up in Montana is like walking into the
hallowed halls of whatever your passion
yeah it's gonna be and so you know I
think I say in the movie you know moving
in Montana it was like stepping into a
National Geographic magazine for real
like in real life you know and so for me
I that was my focus was the outdoors I
was a boy scout you know I was as you
know as you say I had my mom says I had
a lot of energy and for me I think
there's a curiosity that was just
untethered and that comes out in
disruption and about
and you know and then of course we've
got to own it you know at some point you
just start making shitty decisions
you're a teenager growing up with a lot
of single-parent home so in our
community a lot of dads were not in the
picture and so it was not just me you
had a motley crew of guys and gals who
we had we had good parents you know they
were feeding us well we were we had all
the things we may we may or may not have
needed but we were well taken care of
but they were hustling they were working
me a lot of them weren't present and so
we were self educating and that leads to
you know chemicals drugs
you know rebellion making poor decisions
getting in trouble with the law whatever
it may be how much of that do you think
is is a function of you just being a kid
who like wanted to be you know roaming
around outdoors and you're forced to
like sit in a chair you know in a
classroom all day and it just becomes
like an intolerable situation for
somebody who's wired like that yeah
a hundred percent that was the situation
and again it was I like him must say
this for the record as I loved loved
education school you know I mean I'm
right now I'm 36 years old and I'm
thinking about what is my next
continuing education you know to sit and
be educated as stimulating and exciting
to sit and be told to sit to raise your
hand and and and maybe I didn't know how
to say it at 12 but I you know hey got a
question Hey and I would say kid with
the hand up but I was trying to say is
like I'm not learning what you're saying
mm-hmm
and I'm not dumb but I'm just not
getting this well you're somebody who's
learns experientially right absolutely
or you know that just sitting I wasn't
getting to me through with one question
I was allowed every ten minutes or else
I was being nice wrapped it right uh-huh
and so then that what do you do you know
you get cornered by I'm not learning
this and I should be so now I know I'm
behind the eight ball mm-hmm now I'm
also being labeled disruptive and all
I'm trying to do is learn and you got to
do one of two things you you either some
one hand like throws a hand out lifeline
you shouldn't happen or you just give
the middle finger and you're like all
right what's good okay I don't need any
of this and how much of it do you think
is ooh was because you had an out your
dad was gone like your dad left when you
were super
young right yeah yeah dad left what we
were actually still here in LA I think I
was about two months old and you know in
so many ways i I'm glad he did you know
what I have under stand is my mom you
know my dad has had a problem with
alcoholism and my mom was like I don't
want my kids growing up with and maybe
let's just say alcoholism is the banner
that we'll put up but there's all the
things that fall under that under the
disease which is alcoholism and so all
of those other attributes are attributes
that she chose to not have her kids
influenced by and then I think her
fourth you know it meant she had to work
harder it meant she had to do three jobs
it means she had to sell her jewelry and
clothes to put us into school but she
was able to raise us with morals and
values and in this way you know that was
free of the disease of alcoholism you
know we grew up in a home that was free
of a free of that and many other support
parental traits that a lot of kids grew
up with yeah yeah yeah so I'm grateful
for that
yeah he comes back into your life later
yeah yeah and that's a thing so yeah and
you know yes I didn't have a dad growing
up and I'm certain that that impacted me
negatively or that impacted me in a way
that was not really beneficial
considering twelve-year-old kid just
doesn't know what to do with the fact
that they don't have a dad around you
know but dad did come back in the
picture when I was 14 in 93 and grateful
my little sister's a byproduct of that
sort of remarriage and and I think that
was a second time married and and dad we
fade out how to be friends right you
know one of the things that that I loved
about the movie was that as much as it
is a story about like what happened to
you and the other sort of recovery and
the rebuilding of your life and the you
know sort of struggles that that are
packed into that it's really a it's
really a movie about your relationship
with your dad or reconnecting with your
dad and and also with Jen you know is
really kind of you know a protagonist in
the movie but the evolution of
kind of how you find a way with your
father was like a really beautiful like
thematic three line throughout the whole
thing and I feel like the movie is as
much about that as it is about anything
else yeah it is the director the
director the film's Philip Baraboo and
film were talking about as charged and I
chose to not produce the film I chose to
not be a part of that was we were Jen
and I both were highly encouraged to not
produce this film and so we didn't and
what's beautiful is that a team of
creative storytellers took all of this
footage like 386 hours of footage and
edited it and built a human piece
compelling and worth sharing at the tune
of 86 minutes edited and cut and you
know at some point they had to make a
decision do we cut out like all sudden
twiddle down where when it was a two and
a half hour film it was too long and it
had this super beautiful long story line
of Eduardo and his dad in that story but
then the directors ended up cutting that
out because it's them in the film isn't
about it order his dad it's about this
guy's journey through all of these
things which include the dad right but
you know my journey with my father like
I believe I the time I did get with him
on this earth taught me everything I
needed to know about how to not make the
same mistakes he did mm-hm and I apply
those you know I mean not I got 36 years
but you know I got 20 I'll take him
mm-hmm yeah and you're you're the legacy
of his experience I mean you know he has
this love of the outdoors and the water
and you know the fishing and he was a
chef as well and those are all things
that you know are defined you you know
something
and I and I'm Manuelo Fidel Garcia's kid
I grew up without him in my life and I'm
in love drop dead and fated with mother
nature and the outdoors and when I do
finally meet my dad
twelve or thirteen and then over the
next 20 years of having a relationship
together we almost get to connect as two
devotees to the same practice we both
love nature
yeah and he's been doing it 40 years
long but we both get to connect on it
right you know I can't sit in the lineup
without Pelican fly's over I like talk
to it on my dad's back oh yeah oh yeah
like I can't oh no
so where does uh where does cooking come
in you know cooking cooking found me at
an early age it was not you know me on
the buckboard counter with Grandma on
the apron stirring the pot you know like
that was not part of it you know my mom
like I said did a lot of great things
for us cooking was not one of her skill
sets even though she's she's great in
the kitchen she was busy hustling you
know so we would have like 10 p.m.
chicken soup and we'd have that for like
you know five days or something
so cooking for me was hanging with the
homeboys in the summer 14 years old and
13 years old 12 years old and no one no
one available to cook so what do you do
you just open the fridge you start
making it happen you burn some things
you botch some things yeah most people
just eat Fritos they like peanut butter
say no but yeah I know man but we we had
like five pound tubs and miso paste in
the fridge and like you know yeah you
know they mean like we didn't even catch
incense burns for like the communal
dinner at the commune we had Bragg's
amino acid and like bags yeah you know
Tony said like and so whatever will we
ate those things and but you know so
cooking for me professionally was being
15 and I'm just needing a job you know
like I kind of say I was I got I got
tired of stealing quarters from my mom's
purse that she didn't have yeah you know
and got a job at a local place for
burgers throwing pizzas
yeah like Lauren cook yep totally and it
was fun I mean there's a tourism
industry in Montana so you're 15 and
you're with your buddies 15 and you know
you're slinging burgers and watching all
these you know cute girls from out of
town cruising through and it mean it's
like a fun
the summer and I realized well I'm
naturally I can keep up in a kitchen and
you know it was an easy transition into
saying alright well I don't think I have
it in me to do four years of committed
college type of a post-grad work I don't
think I can you know like I couldn't see
myself sitting for four years and but I
knew I knew food is something I keep
doing and so culinary school wasn't easy
all right well let's get educated let's
let's go get a degree in this let's make
this legit was you what you're thinking
like I'm gonna you know be like a fancy
type chef or just want to learn how to
cook better or like what was that did
you have an ambition or like an idea of
where you want to take that I didn't
know not if not at the first no not even
and and it's interesting how many times
in my life have I tried to sell myself
on this false sense of self and knowing
right and the very be like first notion
this will never work but you try to sell
yourself on it for sometimes a day and
sometimes 10 years or longer you know of
being this thing and for me I always
knew like I don't you know I don't I
don't believe I'm going to be that chef
who the way I envisioned it anyway was
I'm I don't think I'm gonna be the chef
that has 10 restaurants all over the
world but but not knowing what was in
front of me was my motive was my impetus
was well I don't know what it's gonna be
but I'm just gonna focus on doing food
and doing it as well as I can
yeah like an adventure a hundred percent
way you head out on our expedition
uh-huh I mean so so then where did my
career take me you know was either gonna
work three jobs and pay off student
loans and you know knock-knock-knock
I got a phone call from a yacht that was
in Seattle saying hey we we need a chef
overnight are you interested in I was
graduating culinary school I was looking
for work and you know I guess humorous
and I turned that job down at that point
I did only five months later to have the
same cabin call me one final time and I
did take that job so the adventure began
you know had no idea what I was gonna do
with this degree in cooking but at that
point
I'd been cooking in restaurants for six
years I knew the rhythm I knew the drill
and knew I was gifted enough to do well
in the industry in regards to palate and
flavors and all of that and I think I
fell into a dream job on so many
different levels and you know it took me
a while to realize the passion for food
but but then the ability to travel the
world and you know learn about cuisine
and all these crazy places and right now
I think I read like you would you take
your skateboard and you do every port
O'Call you'd cruise around go to the
bakeries and various restaurants and now
it was so again that I always say like
you know during my 20s it was an
opportunity to explore but I traded the
mountains than the rivers and sort of
the grizzly bears and all that stuff in
Montana in for you know the map of the
world and you know instead of riding a
horse or hiking I was skating or surfing
or wakeboarding or diving I mean I went
to the water and I did that Jam for ten
years as a yacht chef and we didn't
cover the whole globe but we did a lot
of it right yeah so yeah ten years so
two and a half years on on dorothea
right and then there's total yeah two
and a half years on the yacht dorothea
which I mean that was Captain Mark
trullo who lives down in Encinitas and
just south of us here and talk about an
influential friend mentor a person you
know he he was the type of guy who had
adventured in his life and wanted to
continue adventuring Arabah ed there go
by opening the door for others to do the
same so you know what the option was to
sit on the dock in Point Loma for you
know two weeks or explore Baja for nine
days and once we got on the dock hustle
to get it clean and ready for their
owners or something and like hand would
go up be like adventure yeah like you
kidding me I mean it sounds it sounds
amazing you know what do you what do you
take from that experience like what was
the biggest like lesson that you learned
from just yeah literally a decade of
constant travel yeah
it's uh it was in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean on my first I did four
different crossings of the Atlantic
Ocean on different vessels but on a
sailboat
we crossed we got we started in Majorca
Spain in the Mediterranean and we
crossed to Antigua and it took us about
30 some days when we stopped along the
way and at some point from halfway I
guess between the Canary Islands and
Antigua you know you're in the middle of
the ocean you're about as in the middle
as you can be and and I don't actually I
don't believe in my memory that it was a
typic it was a stormy day or you know
I'm not gonna paint that picture I think
it was just a day at sea and there was
motion of the ocean we're cruising along
and yet there had been rough weather on
either end of it and probably rough to
come and I remember sitting out and
looking at the horizon line and just
kind of having it hit me that there's no
control like the whole notion of control
is kind of out the door you're sitting
you're surrounded in a floating body of
water you cannot breathe er eat it drink
it anything and you are on this man-made
vessel that is your lifeline but
ultimately your peace and your salvation
and all of it just starts within
yourself yeah and like that's the
control is like a misnomer for presence
and a night present it's like being
within yourself being seated it's so
beautiful yeah I mean it's a humility
right yeah it almost like it's
preconditioning you it's it's like
push-ups for what you're gonna have to
face later mm-hmm right yeah I love that
you know like like that experience
problem I would imagine came into play
and helping you whether what you had to
get through must have yeah master I mean
on a prior crossing really really rough
weather bigger boat really rough weather
everyone still has to eat I still have
to get food done and there was a German
and ginger cook with the boat oh it's no
it's nice man it's nuts you know I mean
you're you're
asked against the wall and you're you
know you're kind of like just trying to
find stability and but anyway the German
engineer in the middle of a very gnarly
storm he brings in a little speaker
setup but there's I mean this is before
iPhones this was with his iPod or
whatever it was
mp3 player and he puts on hardcore like
trance electronica music not my usual
Johnny Cash genre you know and and I
roll with it and I realized that he
brings a storm into the kitchen right so
he like brought all of this energy and
this music in this impact into the
kitchen instead of it just being this
chaos around me he's like you gotta
dance with this bro I brought it into
the kitchen and all sudden as you're
cruising and grooving with it you
realize like you forget that the boats
getting tossed around you know you but
you elevate your movement right to match
immediate yeah so like meet that
vibration so rather than fight it or
resist it like hey let's it's not evenly
not only accept it but like I'm gonna
take you one step further right yeah
yeah yeah you know my fiance's uncle was
a very well renowned rock climber
Todd Skinner and one of his quotes I
love is we cannot lower the mountain
therefore we must elevate ourselves
that's the jam yeah that's like I said
Cohen so good yeah cool all right so you
get back you're cooking you're doing
your thing man and so so you know lead
me up to the life-defining
expedition yeah so you know yachting was
a ten eleven year career I realized I
don't want to sleep in a bed that's two
feet wide by a foot and a half tall for
the rest of my life are there people
that do it like their whole lives so I
guess that's guide Encinitas right yeah
no I mean mark mark did it for ages I
have friends who are chefs that started
the same day I started in the yachting
industry that are still doing it and you
know like for me I mean I saw on the way
up here I listened to
Podcast you just put out with you and
Julie right and one of the things she's
she mentioned is only committing to do
and be the thing that is love like that
brings you and creates love like you
know and at some point I realize like
look we can force ourselves to do all
kinds of things and yet that's not your
true self and for me you know for me
it's whatever gets you screaming and
jumping to get out of bed in the morning
that's what you need to be doing more of
and at some point I realized that
cheffing on the boat I was kind of
sleepwalking I was I knew how to do it I
could crush a meal for however many
people or however many days in any
country but I was really looking forward
to my off time when I was building a
food brand and writing a TV show and
focusing on my home back in Montana and
at some point is like you know what I
can no longer continue to work without
the passion I need to chase the passion
which is no longer being a yacht chef
but starting these other businesses and
moving home yeah that was 2010 and yeah
2011 March was making that jump off the
boat right mm-hmm
and so let's let's talk about the
accident
how would so this was what when are we
talking about 2000 2011 a lot left you
know 10 11 year career in the auditing
industry in March was signed with
William Morris Endeavor pitching a TV
show had incorporated a food brand that
was supposed to be like this farmers
market fresh salsas and guacamole
Brianna Mexico versus something but
Montana max yeah Montana Mex stuff right
here dude yeah so before me thanks for
sitting no drama on no president tried
it yet but like I'm looking forward to
so prior to these products that are
sitting with us you know Montana Mex was
a food like the farmers market fresh
movement like perishables yeah yeah and
so that's what we were gunning towards
during the summer of 2011 and my
business partner and ex girlfriend
Jennifer Jane by my side through all of
this in the creation of companies with
our other partners my sister and brother
and and yeah you know what's interesting
is we could get into we could spend two
hours just talking about the day of my
injury but really what was happening in
that point in time was I was
transitioning from being a yacht based
person and having a career in the Outing
industry to being a business owner right
entrepreneur being a host of personality
how did you go from like yacht chef to
like getting an agent at William Morris
yeah yeah one of the guests was Ari
Emanuel's elementary school bro oh
really
uh-huh yeah and we sent we we sent our
sizzle reel to Ari Emanuel and he
immediately sent it on the same day in
the same hour to both offices in North
America in New York and in LA office and
they FaceTime door skype video to each
other and we're like WTF what is this
thing like why what was it about the
sizzle reel like it's like okay you're a
chef like what's the spin like what made
it unique we filmed the sizzle reel
ourselves with it well we know we hired
a production team and we directed the
the shoot and it's the concept if show
was called active ingredient mmm and my
and the premise was that I believe and I
still do that we all we are the active
ingredient in our recipe in our life
rich role you are your own active
ingredient and through all of the other
ingredients which could be our partners
our friends our lovers our kids that we
are the necessary component to activate
all of those into gelling into like yeah
yeah like this is this is the thing
we're sharing this is the prana this is
the food right yes this sounds like a
motivational inspiration well first the
cooking for no totally but so the
cooking the cooking was was the based on
my lifestyle which is if you and I are
gonna go surf or hike or head out into
the woods recreative or be out in the
field even vacationing another country I
want to cook a meal and I want the day
out to incorporate Ella to bring in
elements that we incorporate into the
dinner mm-hmm so active ingredient was
saying like hey we all can find
our truest best selves this show is
about me doing it and I hope it serves
as a metaphor for you in whatever your
active ingredient moment is for me it's
about food it's about cooking and it's
about making it's about bringing others
who are sharing a meal with me and the
low-cal whether that's in the
ingredients or the weather bring that
into the meal maybe I'll take an
experiential a hundred percent yeah
that's what I'm doing I'm ready I want
to watch that I want to see that show
what happened I know right we were
pitching it right now you are good well
we put mean I mean it's tragic right so
we we had a we had a meeting with the
buyer at the Food Network set for
October the 15th and I was flown to the
ICU in Salt Lake City on October the 9th
so four days before that meeting which
you know like contracts had kind of been
drawn up and just we needed to seal the
deal right so bittersweet but you're
resurfacing it again now we have not let
go of that concept and repackaged it
called The Hungry life and we're
pitching it right now so fingers crossed
that's cool man you should have a TV
show yeah thanks I mean I think you're
the perfect person to do it and
especially you know the as an ode in the
legacy of Anthony Bourdain with somebody
with your level of not of life
experience and world exploit with the
travel that you've done but also what
you have gone through to get to this
place like you're you're sitting in a
place where it's not just about the
cooking and the food it's like you have
all of this wealth of information and
insight that you could bring to an
audience that makes it much more dynamic
thank you yeah yeah I appreciate that I
have not let go that we'll see what
happens you know did you ever did you
ever meet Anthony Bourdain did you know
him at all no I knew him how most of the
world knew him through his book sent
through through his voice and influenced
me greatly yeah influenced me greatly
that's a lot of people oh yeah tough man
oh yeah
all right so so you're this is what you
have all this momentum happening yeah
life yeah and walk me through the day
yeah so
I was I was out elk hunting yeah you
know as a the shed there's a there's a
part of me as a chef that loves to know
where my food comes from whether it's
the carrots in my in my garden or
whether it's you know an animal-based
protein like I want to know I want to
know more the story about it and I want
to be involved in that so hunting is has
always been a part of my life and I it's
interesting you know I as a hunter
I often prior to a harvest take a moment
to connect with the animal in life and
the and and just you know I don't need
to make this sound all woowoo but in the
line you're talking to a vegan see yeah
yeah well you know but IND I don't know
who's listening and I just wanted a lot
of vegans yeah so a lot of other people
so but I bet I'd so I do this when I you
know like I'm putting a garden in on
Saturday so when I get home tomorrow and
it'd be in the garden all day so even
when I'm pulling a plant up is it
thinking about it like is this
strawberry ready has it done its thing
is this have I over harvested this
asparagus patch of whatever it is anyway
the morning I'm out hunting I pass on an
animal I decided not to harvest that
animal for my reasons and I end up
resetting what was it about like
something just didn't feel right to you
you know I I had had kind of told myself
I want to harvest this I want to harvest
a younger a younger cow elk or you know
a younger female elk not what I saw in
front of me that day which was this huge
beautiful male elk which 99% hunters
around the world would be like why in
the heck didn't you you know wasn't what
I wanted and I think intention right
reason right motive right cause like
intention is huge you know like you know
that wasn't my intention for that day so
although I could have been seduced by
how big and beautiful this thing look no
so I decided to keep going hiking later
on the afternoon and I come across a I'm
just to put this in perspective for
everyone I'm in a valley
about 5,000 feet and I'm heading from
the sage sort of valley floor winding my
way three miles up into the conifer or
evergreen forests and within those that
forest there's we're still you know
everything is sloped you know gentle
rolling up and I'm in a little drainage
small small drainage and I see a can
like literally a 50-gallon oil drum cut
in half on the ground and curious I walk
up to it and when I was a weird thing to
see which is a weird world which is a
weird thing to see except you know
except in the Rocky Mountain West and
even in many parts of California here
there is a lot of debt richest there's a
lot of left over a mining camp sheep
camp homestead junk out in the woods
from our predecessors you know from the
folks that were here before us
and I just assumed like that's an old
camps camps something you know and I
look inside and there's what literally
just envisioned a black to pay everybody
with like a claw r2 and some bone you
know the size of like a volleyball like
deflated that's what I see in the bottom
of this can and I'm like what the heck
is that you know and growing up you know
a student of the outdoors I mean I've
picked up every feather I've checked out
every animal dropping like you know I
study at all and so I think huh that's
interesting and part of me thinks well
it looks like a very like two to three
year old dead like been here for three
years dead baby bear cub or something
and so I pull a knife off my right hip
and I put it in my left hand and my plan
is just to take a cloth off just like
you would harvest you know a interesting
branch or something that's you know
fallen and I'm gonna take the claw and
you know put in a curiosity case or make
it a necklace or give it to my friend
who works at the Boy Scouts and is
always collecting to teach with you know
and I mean I don't even get within 15
inches of the base of this can before
2400 volts of electricity arcs into the
tip of the knife I'm holding and into my
body you didn't even touch
mm-hmm it's just jumped at the metal it
arced into it at art and its interests I
had both hands going down to this barrel
I'm on my knees I'm leaning over I have
both hands and you know because like the
knife is gonna pop the cloth in the
right hand it's gonna pick it up and
teamwork and what's interesting is had I
not been holding that knife like nothing
would have happened but that knife
curated a conduit for that electricity
Jarnell so had you just had you touched
it with your hand though you it would
have conducted the electricity wouldn't
it or was it it was you had to have
Medellin yeah I think it was the metal
and so what what what was going on was
there was a there was a an exposed power
cord beneath the tank it was a bear it
was a buried line that was going to a
backcountry cabin and this can was
sitting on sort of a point where the
line had like it was like it was a
ground junction access point and the lid
had many you know and so what I come to
understand you know and what I can share
is that you know this junction box had
been compromised by weather and neglect
and time and was not maintained and the
lid became unsecure and fell off it
should have never been exposed I mean it
should have been labeled and fenced and
the whole thing so you know in that
moment I knew none of this right now
Morris I mean how would you think like
better not touch that like there's there
might be an exposed wire underneath I
mean you wouldn't do it contrary it's
it's you know the the only thought would
be should I touch that it look as gross
like that's the thought you know so how
many volts 2,400 2,400 volts yeah
and does it just hurl you like what hot
was so I wait so I wake up right so I
wake up on on my back staying I wake up
staring at the clouds in treetops and I
you know I at this point all I know is
that I'm staring at the clouds did you
know that you were electrocuted and now
what it if knowing that knowing that
moment in the moment I got electrocuted
it was like someone had inserted me into
inside the speaker cable of like a yes
con
or something it was just straight up
electronic symphony in the back of my
head with heat with like the gentle warm
flood of heat lights out my eyes open up
I don't know how many minutes later and
I see clouds and dappled blue sky and
treetops and and I think to myself get
up get up what are you doing now roll
over and I'm on my knees in my hands
hands and knees and I say get to your
feet in this so this is all I remember
is just talking to myself to get to
stand up and I must have stood up and
I'm next to this barrel all my gear my
backpack my bow my things and the next
memory I have is just me is is the next
memory I have is of the sound of gravel
and I'm on the dirt road I'm no longer
in the trees I'm no longer next to that
can I don't have any of my things with
me except in my right hand I'm holding
the can of bear spray in my left hand I
looked down at it
and it is blackened and burnt and seized
into like a claw shape you know right
and and what's the pain like not
anything or you know in this weird
adrenaline yeah like no dream mode total
total dream mode total jury mode I mean
I I gathered where I was okay I'm in
this part I'm in this valley this I'm
walking downhill why am i walking
downhill why is my hand black and then
of course like oh yeah I saw like I saw
that like dead baby bear I went to get a
claw I put a knife and then it's like oh
man that noise that he didn't like it I
must have got zapped I mean we've all
been zapped through static electricity
or the random one time where you get a
little too close to something and it was
you know it like zaps you back and I
think again life experienced those small
little
tidbits of being in touch with
electricity in my life definitely all
sudden come fall Center I'm like wow I
think you actually just received I think
you just got electrocuted like bad and
now I take account now now my heads on a
swivel and I look I look at the hand and
it's grotesquely disfigured in black and
gripped into a claw I look at my leg on
my left thigh and I see that my pants
are black and I kind of poke a finger
through there and I can see it's just
charred flesh and I don't have to look
anymore now I realize that I am walking
down this road to get help and this was
a subconscious decision I made when I
was know like not in my body you know in
our unconscious mind just went into
survival mode hundred without any memory
of that hundred no one I don't I don't
think we remember the day that the day
the moment were born and take our first
breath outside of our umbilical cord
you know but it happens and how do we
know to do that that's the miracle
genetically wired to do it yeah so do
you have like a Sat phone or a cell
phone
soon there's no service or anything like
that like you're way out back country
right the cell phone the keys to the
track the water daughter stayed tilt
back it's all it's all on the ground and
how far are you from like civilization
either help I'm about three miles I mean
I've gone back to the site many times
I've retraced all these things and I'm
about three miles from where I received
help and and was what's just interesting
is that I'm carrying my bear spray
somehow in that collected moment of
getting to my feet and leaving the site
I make a decision to not carry anything
but bear spray like just think about
that first thing it's like Morrow it's
like anyone ever packed for that trip
where you're running out of time and you
need to get out the door by this time or
you will not make your flight or
something and you just have to decide
what to take and what not to take it's
like triage it's like I just got to get
there well it's all the more remarkable
I mean when you see the movie and you
see we're gonna talk about this in a
minute but like when when you see the
condition that you're
it's not just your arm like it's the
right head it's your like the fact that
you could do anything is shocking like
the fact that you walked three miles
well you see what your body look like
it's it's just unbelievable that you
didn't just die on the spot yeah it's
it's the flipside of watching the
Olympics
you know those folks are training and
putting everything they have for decades
into being their most Max and myself and
I think dying and surviving an
experience like that is the flip side is
you are using everything in your tank
every facet of every ounce of energy you
have to towards salvation mmm like no
doubt mm-hmm no doubt it's the flip side
but it's also similar you're tapping
into every reservoir that you have to
accomplish your goal and that goal may
be a gold medal on a podium or in hate
beaches living yeah right no and it's I
mean okay so here is here's the million
dollar question which is like how do we
access like that type of clarity that
type of conviction and that type of
follow-through and execution I call me
on the daily bro yeah I mean I would
like to know the answer to that are you
here to look reveal this secret to me
well I'm hoping that charged the film
somehow inspires all of us to at least
be aware of it and recognize that deep
within all of us there is a almighty
power like deep inside and yet it's time
you know that that we we cover ourselves
up in all the layers that you know are
shed immediately when it's time to fight
or flight like it's immediate but when
it's kind of everyday life we are held
back by all the stuff man yeah we become
myopic I mean you know my story is about
change forged through pain a different
kind and certainly not as severe and I
think that that you know like I said
earlier like these these obstacles that
are placed in our path are teachable
moments to help us get closer to who we
really are
and I think that's a big part of your
story in a very extreme way but why is
it that you know I can't change and tell
I'm in pain or that pain is required or
obstacles are required or hardship is
required or overcoming these things is
required in order to get in touch with
the fact that it is about the moment
that it is about gratitude and love and
appreciation and service and sharing and
all of these things that are innately
part of who we are and available to us
as a choice on a daily basis to use as
guiding principles in our life and and
in our behavior and yet are so much more
difficult to access when we're just when
things are okay yeah you know it's true
it's true and that's I mean you can
fast-forward or however we want to do
this but I mean that that was part of
that was most of my reasoning to be
available and agree to have a
documentary made about this tragedy in
my life was just that sort of the to be
a part of creating something that serves
as a reminder to others and myself
included that this is just part of the
this is part of the jam this is life man
this is how it this is what it looks
like this is what it feels like and and
actually what's for charge for the
documentary I mean we as collectively as
a group we're in a very unique position
that we were filming this TV show right
and so we had footage well professional
you know like quality capture footage
from years prior leading up until the
day of the injury mm-hmm and day four of
being in ICU and you know Rosa lon the
production company were working with
citizen pictures at a Denver you know
they show up not to document but they
showed up to be like holy yeah are you
okay into you know respectfully and
lovingly show up but of course they you
know we talked to him and jenni arranged
and they brought a camera they brought a
light and then a friend drove down with
our camera and you know Jenni Jane
rolled rolled that camera through
and captured still photos and video that
I think all the way through the fifty
days of I see you and then in the next
couple years she continued document and
then even a friend of ours Phil Baraboo
who ended up being the director on the
film not knowing why we're capturing
rice except maybe Jen Jen Jen I think
knew there could be something to salvage
from all this and I think Phil as being
I mean he's a documentary Stewart
filmmaker he's had you know he probably
saw that coming
and for me I was just I remember naively
saying well we're capturing this because
you know my hope is it never happens
again and I don't want to have to
remember it through experience like I
wanted I'd like to be able to for
posterity for your cell phone yeah you
know like I don't need I don't want to
have to get zapped again to remember
this and so that but that serves us like
we serve back to like why this film what
do others get from it and well we're
we're creatures of story I mean that is
that's part of who we are and there's
nothing that that can move the human
soul more than an incredible story well
told right that's how like you as an
experiential learner I think us as
creatures we can read text books but
when we hear when somebody shares their
experience and they do it in a
compelling way and it's an extraordinary
story I think it has the ability to
connect with us as animals in a certain
way that other information cannot and
you know your story is a perfect example
of that and it's so I mean that's the
thing when you're watching the movie
you're like oh my god like there's a
gate like I think there were a couple
places where it looked like okay are
they like they had to recreate you going
you know touching the knife and all of
that but like post-accident
like they're right there like it felt
like day one through the entire process
and I want to work my way up to that
because that footage in the hospital is
is excruciating to watch when you see
the physical condition that you are
actually in I mean in occur in a very
graphic way I've never seen anything
like that you know I think you're
obviously when people meet you they see
your arm
your hand immediately and it's like okay
he lost his arm his forearm in his hand
but your torso I mean it's it is just
charred to nothing like half of your
upper body is essentially gone and it
looked almost like like the ribs were
just black it looked there was like just
a hole into your into your organs right
there I mean it was unbelievable oh yeah
and there you are and you're like you
got a smile on your face and you're like
cracking jokes on my house this guy even
hit haunches right now rich has on so
many drugs Manatee yeah those are wrote
down like ask him what everybody must be
you know we're gonna get administer
ketamine mr. Garcia hmm well what's that
you probably hear I've known it a
Special K hey what are you trying to
imply you know like they say that in ICU
they have a really big issue with folks
who have severe recreational you know
chemical dependency recreation tolerance
is so hard their tolerance is so high
they can't medicate it you know but I
you know I look I think obviously the my
care team did a phenomenal job keeping
me at a threshold that was tolerable
mm-hmm
I don't know why I have a hard time
talking about this or to like get
wrapping my head around like the whole
concept that we all had different
tolerances for pain and you know maybe I
have an issue with if I say like hey
rich I have a really high tolerance for
pain I think I've heard that and it's
hit me as this like ego lace-like
macho type of thing but in reality I
think I have a higher tolerance for pain
than a lot of folks and I also I've
experienced a lot of pain and I've been
in ICU a lot maybe not for my own
experience a few times from my
experience but I've had a lot of a few
yeah you know with my dad
when he had heart surgery in 2005 like
that one time when I did this when I
broke my wrist three times like I've
been in and out of those scenarios a lot
and then I got to say like look I know
this sounds strange but
I don't I don't fear death you know like
I understand the process here I get it
is that a result of that experience or
did you have that before this occurred
I think it's compounded through this
experience but it's been around and it I
think a lot of it has to do with killing
a deer for the first time when I was 11
years old and watching life disappear
and and and then working in a garden a
lot of my life like I stopped I mean I'm
this all like I stop pulling live
flowers off of stuff because I was like
man I don't see a die I'm gonna find ya
like I've been a I just been a so
closely connected with life and death
through my lifestyle for so long that
look I'm not saying that changed the
game but I think it wasn't new the
scenario wasn't new right so my approach
was alright this is a job this is what's
happening and I have a role to play here
and so I did that yeah part of that the
humility cycle of life being in nature
understanding it's not personal
yeah right yeah and look I I have never
actually offered that as a as a
conversation point when asked like how
was your experience and I see you I just
hit on that right now here with you
because of how we're talking and you
know the way it came to me but I I do
want to say that I think one of the
greatest prescriptions that you know I
didn't I didn't I didn't have given to
me was ignorance is I just didn't know
how close I was to death I like so many
times Eduardo you know shows up to the
scene or shows up to the moment of and
through the whole way I am
I just didn't know I didn't know and
therefore if you don't know you're about
to die mmm-hmm
you know I'm gonna take it as seriously
as I think that comes across in the
movie I mean I got ya cuz I'm watching
you and I'm like this guy doesn't
realize the severity in the situation
that he said I mean anyway skull is
missing yeah and you can like literally
see inside his torso oh you know and and
your thigh I mean a giant literally like
you put your hand
inside your thigh at one point like when
you're laying in bed right you lift up
and it's like somebody had just carved
you know just this massive chunk out of
your leg yeah and you're like this guy's
not gonna make it
I mean I felt I felt supported you know
and I think here I mean that's the
that's the thing is supported by your
community Jan your family or supported
in and like a like a more broader
spiritual sense all of the above you
know I I felt so the only I came out of
a surgery - so you're talking about the
hole in my torso my ribs so indeed right
so like in front of it right now right
which is missing a bunch of ribs I'm
still missing those ribs I'm like
pushing on my torso and it's like
bobbing like a beach ball right now but
I had four to the three inch sections of
ribs removed and coming out of that
surgery there was a miscommunication was
with the anesthesiologist and I came off
of that surgery on a lower epidural dose
than I should have had and I was an
excruciating pain I was in the most pain
I've ever felt in my life coming out of
that surgery and a friend of ours who
just search and rescue with his dogs all
over the world happened to be coming
through Salt Lake and came into the ICU
on that day to say hi to me and his name
is arturo Hakuna a good friend and our
doodle knelt by my bed as I'm just out
of the surgery and starting to feel pain
come on because the indices of surgery
is wearing off and Arturo I'm in so much
pain I can't speak I can't let alone
just focus on breathing for hours I did
this you know and our tutor whispered in
my ear about the earthquake in Haiti you
know almost what ten years ago now or
whenever that was and he shares a very
short story about his experience in
Haiti for maybe a minute or two just to
tee up the lesson which is hey be
grateful for what you do have you're in
the best house possible you have the
best care possible you're surrounded by
loved ones there's no lack of blood for
transfusions there's no lack of care it
could be worse so for that
anesthesiologist you scream yeah yeah
you know exactly yeah exactly in in it
but that just that hit me like a ton of
bricks you know I'm just like that's
right I I'm doing I'm doing great all
things considered the thing that I think
struck me the most in the whole movie is
and you could chalk it up to naivete or
what-have-you but there's something
about you like throughout this whole
process you're in ICU 40 48 days yeah
not once I mean maybe you did off-camera
but like not once did I see you complain
or play the victim like you have a smile
on your face you're making everyone who
comes in to see you comfortable and you
have this this not just hope like
optimism and just sense of joy and
gratitude about you and I want to know
like where that comes from because
that's not faked and I don't think that
that was learned through the the tragedy
the tragic accident I think that's just
part of who you are that's core now
that's that's that's core to Who I am
that's core to Who I am and I am I can
lead and I'm also a really good soldier
I'm a really good team player and in
that scenario the only thing that I was
leading was attitude if I could smile if
I could grin if I could twinkle and I if
I could really share that my genuine
effort with everybody around me they
were gonna leave my recovery in that
moment and I was conscious of adopting
that perspective or was that just
natural yeah both I mean natural it
naturally occurred and came out of me
and then I was aware and encouraged by
my own actions like oh yeah this is what
I can do this is how
to the point where a nurse you know a
couple my nurses would be like hey don't
be afraid it's okay brave a little bit
and be emotional and let it out you
don't want to be repressing Brighton's
either and that was her concern in that
one moment but but like I will share too
that that's my mo that's how I choose
that's my typical approach however there
is a Jekyll and Hyde in this guy and you
know to give my family credit and
definitely my ex-girlfriend Jennie Jane
who flew back from England to be my
caregiver and held me and be by my side
you know there were durations of time
where I reflect back now I'm like I was
really nasty
I had no patience I had no tolerance and
yeah but that's to be expected sure but
you know and so so it's to be expected
and but I think at some point I think
that no matter like you know you get a
cough or a cold or when we are out of
sorts our patience drops our tolerance
level drops that doesn't mean that's an
excuse to take the piss and just kind of
do that every time we still owe it to
ourselves and those we love and those
around us to make the effort to be
pleasant etc which I was but I'm just
saying that even though the film shares
I never made an edit on the film like
they did a masterful job however I have
had comments from folks say like hey
like when did you struggle because we
don't see it in the film like we need a
little but you know what I saw was I
mean the first time that you see you
struggling with this is the day that you
get out of the hospital and you're
forced to like okay now it's time to go
back to your life and it felt like and I
don't know how much of this happens in
the Edit and what's real versus like you
know creating a narrative but that's the
first time where we see you break down
and it feels like it's all dawning on
you what has actually happened like you
had to remain like it's another type of
fight or flight survival mode okay your
NICU for 48 days like you have to keep
it together to survive this
and then once they release you it's
almost like a pressure valve release and
then you're like oh wait and it felt
like a ton of bricks just landed on you
and you're like oh my god that's what
just happened and this is where I'm at
my life a hundred percent that was that
that was the second that was the second
sort of wake-up call emotional wake-up
call I had and I was scared I was
freaked out I was scared you kidding me
leaving ICU after 50 days of almost
dying and knowing that it's just me and
Jen and not 20 nurses and an on-call
staff and a medication team and what
were the doctors telling you like when
you first came in and they have to say
like you know what's the prognosis here
what are we looking at
yeah dr. William Morris who was the
surgeon on call that did save my life
I think he's quoted as saying that's a
bag of bones with a heartbeat
basically like oh man chance yeah like
what you were literally toast toast yeah
you know and and so I I only now realize
how close I was to dying that day and
even for the next three days pretty
dicey you know but for the emotional
part I just want to share you know
Richie mentioned that scene where I'm
walking out of the hospital I'm being
discharged and I break down and that's
the first time we really see there's
sort of the beginnings of the emotional
dawning of what's happening and there
was one there was one moment prior
because we talked about being strong and
like the heat of the fire and how you
you know how to smile and be courageous
in ICU and how that happened and that
was very much my personality but there
was a moment where Jen and I were
watching a movie she was on my left side
and so that's the so it watching a film
on our laptop so I'm in my hospital bed
Jen is either in the bed with me or
sitting next right next to it we're
watching my laptop watching a movie and
in my mind I am caressing her knee like
I have my hand on her knee and I'm like
just you know touching it just like you
would kind of put a hand on your
significant you know
and then at some point I look over and
it hits and I realize like I don't have
a hand on my left arm anymore and what I
was feeling was thirty years of memory
that when you sit next to someone you
care about to watch a movie you throw an
arm over and and you just touch them on
their leg or their shoulder or the
Phantom yeah it was it was in my mind it
was so real and I and I remember just
breaking down in that moment that there
was gonna have to be a whole mental
shift that right you no longer have a
left hand guy so they they amputate up
to like like halfway up your forearm
right yeah that where it is mm-hmm and
what do they do to your torso and your
and your head and your thigh yeah graft
skin on there like what was the process
of like healing from that yeah I mean
the for the most part that 48 day stay
was you know up to 12 surgeries which
was every other day every three days
every four days a surgery grafting skin
harvesting skin from a healthy part of
your body and using it to cover and
rebuild skin on a wooden site you know
and that was that was every day you know
and actually we stopped my surgery short
we stopped my surgeries short because it
was let's say it was mid way through my
stay one of my exit wounds was in my
scrotum and as the surgeons through
their process are cleaning up all the
dead tissue on my body I go into a
surgery and they come out of the surgery
and they're like you know you get a
report or a debrief and you know hey we
couldn't save your left teste or
whatever it was and you know I'm losing
so many body parts and bits and pieces
that it's just kind of like okay yeah
yeah I mean something you didn't think
that was on on the menu for oh man I bet
there's some listeners been like whoa
whoa whoa what about like you think it's
bad and then it's like all right you
know you're gonna lose this - yeah like
but that wasn't part of the deal no it
wasn't and
and yet so the doctor leaves right and
and my brothers in the room and and Jen
and I don't know who else and I and the
nurse there's a nurse in the room and I
just kind of share to the room maybe my
brother who ever like huh well I never
never liked that one anyway that was one
that always gave me problems and I don't
know if my brother asked well what do
you mean by problems or if I shared but
you know years prior while yachting
years years prior I remember having a
pain in my groin I remember having a
doctor check it out squeeze squeeze pull
pull you look fine
you know you're on your feet 20 hours a
day you're probably just pulled of
something taking ibuprofen and I just
put that idea to bed that I needed to
look into my physical health but in that
moment when they're like oh you just
lost your left teste I thought to myself
like that memory shut up and I was like
oh wait
years ago I had an issue with that thing
like good riddance
my brother chases the surgeon down the
hall and it's like hey just want to
throw this out there after you left the
room
Eduardo mentioned this and I don't know
what you do with that and so that kind
of set an alarm off and the doctors head
or the surgeons and they so they went to
every body part that every piece that
leaves you goes to the lab and they run
the results so he had that test II ran
and came back with positive tumor
markers or seminoma testicular cancer so
you just can't get a break yeah right
yeah yeah there's that fun there's a
funny scene in the movie where Chan's
like yeah you know because you you had
your ups and downs in this relationship
and and she's in a position where she
has to sign off on the removal of the
testicle of her ex-boyfriend you know
she and she also is like good riddance
yeah yeah exactly right yeah exacting
her little like revenge as she's taking
care of you 24 hours a day
yeah totally she jen is a is a voracious
screenwriter and sticks to comedy
stand-up comedian as well and so just
that actual reality that the girlfriend
that got cheated on gets to sign away
right the ex-boyfriends you know
testicle is like I mean how good does it
get yeah you can't you can't write you
can't talk about
I mean come on like alright you're
literally hanging on for your life yeah
it's like oh by the way you have
testicular cancer and then they find it
in your spine so they're so then of
course I mean the red lights go on the
sirens blare and and I get a whole panel
done and cat-scans and there was a mass
of tissue in my lower abdomen right up
against my spine that was just assumed
to be trauma related to the
electrocution but not of concern and now
all of a sudden they're like wait a
minute that could be a second stage
tumor and so I mean it was just insane
you know I'm I don't even know how to
talk about it in short verse you know
because I'm in the hospital having my
life saved limbs are getting chopped off
left right and center I'm losing all
these pieces of my body and and I'm just
trying to make it through these
surgeries man you know like I am just
trying to see the light at the end of
the tunnel to be courageous to not give
up to believe that it's all gonna be
cool and then oh and you have testicular
cancer by the way and so at that point I
was just
I remember being frustrated and I mean
it's frustrated that's that's it right
but frustrated because I was eagerly
anticipating knocking these things out
and getting back to life like just
getting back to what I wanted to go do
et cetera and now I have to stop my
surgeries I go do rigorous chemotherapy
in Montana for three months I got the
choice Salt Lake City go home
I went home how where were you in the
process of you know recovering from all
the injuries at that point like right so
I mean halfway I still had pending
surgeries to reconstruct reconstructing
my scalp so I stopped you know we
stopped kind of closed all my wounds up
got myself stable went through
chemotherapy and then when I finished my
last round of chemo took up remedial
surgery on my amputated forearm to clean
up that that site and then did another
years worth of plastic surgery work
scalp so we really I mean it's slowed
things down and extended another 12
months of recovery and surgeries you're
trying to your body's trying to repair
itself from these cataclysmic injuries
and then you know okay so now we're
gonna just bombard it with chemotherapy
and right crush your immune system and
right I can't imagine like you know the
the body must have just been like shut
down yeah you know yeah it it that I
mean it was I mean that is not what
chemotherapy does it kills all your
rapidly producing cells and I I had a
goal if I hiked every single day that
I've sat in that infusion chair I would
like keep it was like me against
chemotherapy and I may not win at least
stay above it but I was gonna meet it
toe to toe every day right yeah and your
cancer for you now yeah as I'm told I
get a check-up once a year right right
right
Wow so so how many surgeries all told
about 21 yeah yeah how did they fix your
head it's amazing I have a listen and a
plastic surgery you know it's such a
misnomer that I mean plastic surgery is
for all of these you know we use them
for whatever we want plastic surgery to
be but I mean never forget walking into
quarry a grocer jhin's office and
there's all these different breast cup
sizes on her counter as a display you
know like dozens of them and you know
that's her work so she you know she's
talking about what they are and I
realized that classic surgery is is a in
incredible piece of technology that
allows people to return back to their
most complete physical sense and you
know and so for me I had two giant like
the size of an orange wounds in my scalp
where my skull was intact but my scalp
was gone on one on my forehead which you
can't see and went on on the right side
of my head and and they basically
inserted baggies and stretched my skin
out and when there was nothing last
isset II in that stretch skin they
pulled it over the chunk of skull that
no longer had scalp I mean just extra
ordinary process yeah cuz I can't
looking at you right now like I can't
see anything but when you watch the
movie you're like like you know and your
torso you know it's in the movie you see
without your shirt on like once it's
healed it's remarkable how normal it
looks the surgeons did an incredible job
keeping my torso symmetrical so my my
latissimus was is connected from your
hip and runs up to your scapula and they
removed they disconnected it from my hip
and and brought it basically out the
side and then what's called a muscle
flap and they used it and pulled it over
my torso and my abdominals to cover that
lack of a body matter right that was you
know my obliques half of my obliques
half of my pectoral muscle my less I
were all removed and the way the surgeon
says he's like we just removed all this
muscle from you and we have to fill it
back in with something yeah and but you
still have unbelievable range of motion
considering you you're lacking all that
that's those structural muscles on one
side of your body like how are you even
able to like move your arm and your
shoulder so I asked that are you doing
pull-ups like how does that work without
laughs I asked I asked that question I
said so like how does this work you know
you're telling me half of my obliques
all left side half my obliques half my
pectoral my down abdominals my
latissimus all all being removed and and
either is gone or being you know my
latissimus is still there but it's
brought over and no longer serving the
production place yeah it's just at your
feet as a filler and my doctor just you
know it's like well you have all of
these subsets of mine subsets of minor
muscle groups below the major groups and
with the big group not present or that
large muscle not present those smaller
muscles are going to kick into gear and
start working and developing and growing
stronger in lieu of big brother no
longer being there and that's what I've
experienced I mean it look when you know
I'm missing a huge chunk of my left
quadricep and I don't know if anyone out
there believes in karma or what it is
but I'm like all of these things are
left side on my body whether it's the
hand the testicle the muscles everything
is all left side for the most part
and so you'd think that the entire left
side of my movements would be totally
off and I am just grateful that the way
I was put back together that I can run
and jump and bike and swim and do my
thing without really with with no
noticeable skew to the left height move
yeah
which isn't crap when you're running it
looks totally normal yeah which is crazy
I mean the amount of muscle removed from
your quad is like you know a giant
sirloin yeah and yet when I hike you
know if I'm going vertical up a hill or
if I'm by any if I'm locomotive I'm
moving I don't feel that and and I truly
believe that whatever they all these
supporting muscles just rallied on that
side and said this side needs to be as
strong as the other side let's go it's
interesting that the only real injury on
the right on your right side isn't is in
your head to the brain but the right
side of the brain controls the left side
right that's wild
that is well yeah and we should say just
because I don't know that we've made it
clear these injuries like it was the
electricity leaving your body right the
electricity like exiting your body
literally through your skull through
your torso and through your quad yeah
not 9 to 5 in your hand yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy and what you have but you
have some scars on your right hand is
that from something different no that's
exit that's exit 2 they're just a little
less severe then yeah the ones yeah they
it's not something you know you look at
those scars you know and and and I
always say that our scars are sort of
the road map that shows us how we got
here you know emotional scars physical
scars yeah I think you know that's
that's sort of how you end the movie
like how do you you know looking back on
this experience like how do you process
it and like how do you think about how
it informs your life yeah I thought I
was just saying he's quite simply I'm
still working on that every like [ __ ]
you know I woke up today in LA and came
out here and
my morning was spent talking to my
fiance about our future plans right now
and I'm reminded every single day in a
very positive welcoming way about this
injury you know it's like I don't wake
up every day say oh man I wish I wasn't
an amputee or oh man you know like I
wish I had in the last three years of my
life to that it's rather like oh man
what am i doing today and I'm gonna be
sure to not agree to do anything or to
put myself into any scenario that's not
exactly how I want my life to be mm-hmm
so it's you know in so many ways on the
outside and at first glance if you we've
never met and you never heard the story
it's like that's the most tragic thing
I've ever heard and then on the other
hand it's like a blessing because it's a
daily reminder to just go get it do you
wish that it hadn't happened or do you
feel like in some weird way by having
these things removed that it has
completed you I I i do not wish that
this didn't happen hold on a second you
don't wish that it didn't have wait what
like some folks are like oh would you go
back yeah would you would you go back if
you could go back to 2011 and not get
electrocuted would you do it and at this
point absolutely like no I love the
person I am today and I am blessed with
the opportunity to still be alive
and share my experience with others like
mine but that it it enriches my
experience here you know and yeah it
enriches my experience my mom my mom
says something along the lines of we all
need to we all are better well served
understanding humility and look I'm not
saying anyone wishes something like this
on anybody
the point being is that humility can be
found through so many different ways and
I could tell you right now that I am
better off today than I was prior to
this injury given sort of my connection
with my heart my true self my desires my
physical person in the world prior to
that probably little imbalance probably
getting a little too far ahead of myself
with like I'm gonna do this I'm gonna be
this and I'm gonna go this way
and and more so today in large part
because of this injury I don't get so
far away from that like hey don't forget
who you are
I mean who you need to be in this world
yeah you've literally been forced to
slow down physically like there are
those sequences in the movie where it's
like you want to go in the kitchen and
like Bam Bam Bam and like do it the way
it was like no it's not gonna work out I
do you're gonna have to like yeah chill
like chill bro
right but that compulsion on a physical
level to slow down seems like it then
makes its way into your kind of
emotional spiritual you know body and
perspective to go hey man let's just
like be here right now yeah how can we
honor this moment in a different way
yeah we started this conversation
talking about a show called active
ingredient whereby pre-injury Eduardo
believed that there you know that we are
all the integral part of our own best
recipe of self right and like I wrote
that show you know like I believed that
and yet post-injury I get like I live
and walk that now way more that's we're
interesting because yeah you it's almost
like you literally had to burn in this
fire to become that person that you sort
of thought you were beforehand that you
were trying to embody but you actually
weren't that guy now you are that guy
you can carry that vibration in a way
that when because I'm sure it's gonna
happen this show happens that you can be
that impactful voice that you always
want it to be that perhaps you
thought you were before but now you
actually really are yeah like in
recovery and they always say like you
can't transmit something you haven't got
you could talk about transmitting
something you haven't got but if you're
not backing it up with actually who you
are and your life experience like if you
haven't lived it enough then you could
talk about it but it's not gonna connect
with anyone else
yeah like unconsciously we know you know
like is that guy full of it or is that
guy like the real thing yeah yeah
exactly and um across the board right so
like whether it's you know the Eduardo
pre the injury wanted to share my love
of life with the world on the largest
platform possible okay I'm gonna be a TV
show host and I'm gonna create and sell
a TV show the why behind that was
genuine and authentic but like Oh like
it just didn't maybe it didn't have that
level of understanding and like
authentic experience to add to it you
you know and you know as well as with
the food company you know with Montana
Mex like I had been cooking for most of
my adult life and I had been cooking for
the last decade for families for kids
like really really inspired by the fact
that I was a conduit between life and
death for people like we got to eat
everyday you know and so being a part of
how people eat was a beautiful part of
my life and like going into that injury
but coming out of that injury still
having the food company Montana Mex
I only came out of that injury stronger
in every single conviction like yes I
still want to share my passion with the
world and my belief that we are our own
active ingredient yes I want to talk to
the world on the largest scale possible
about how national food companies can be
free of all of this junk of all of this
stuff can be philanthropic can give back
can make better business sense I mean in
every step in every sense of the word
stronger your your your a literal
conduit between life and death in a very
different way
than what you described you know you
could carry Pryor right yeah yeah in an
emotional way yeah charged I mean what's
funny it's like grounded to like you
literally like you know the word
grounded like from you know in an
electrical sense you know but grounded
in a very emotional and spiritual sense
as well like you can own your you can
own your footing in a way that you
couldn't before and look you don't do
especially as a young person like you
don't like aspire to have a TV show
unless there's some ego involved right
so what is the and and that's fine egos
fine unless it's out of balance so what
is the balance of ego in that equation
versus from then versus now yeah yeah I
think there's a certain amount of maybe
I mean you can and may help me out you
know maybe there's a word outside of ego
that is that thing within you that knows
it is desirable knows that it is capable
knows that it is valuable and you know I
think we associate you go into the sense
of I I am this I am that and and yet at
some point I needed a certain amount of
whatever that was just to make it
through that time sure I needed to
believe that I could do this I was gonna
be okay like I could add value to the
team around me but the humility that is
often not present with ego is definitely
something that I pulled out of that fire
yeah it's like I can believe myself all
day long but you need to be like be
yourself to you and yourself is not that
guy that you left behind ten years ago
or at that you know yeah I would imagine
that it's some combination of like the
strength that comes from self belief
that I guess on some part it's derived
from ego and if there isn't a word from
what you just described there should be
balancing that against deep humility and
really like a surrender to the fact that
you have so little control over this
right like like you're in that boat
being tossed around by those
waves and urine and I see you you know
at the behest of a team of doctors who
are doing their best but like there's
very little that you can do what are the
things you can control you can control
your attitude how your how you're acting
towards you know your medical stuff and
the loved ones that are that are
caretaking for you and your frame of
mind yeah where your your optimism or
pessimism about what is actually
occurring in real time yeah it's true
but the surrender part and I think this
gets I'm interested in your thoughts on
this I think what gets lost when we talk
about surrender is that we we sort of
think that that means giving up or you
know that letting go is a weakness hmm
but in my experience and I'm interested
in yours like surrendering creates like
a freedom and a different kind of
strength to approach a problem from a
more empowered and humble perspective
that ultimately in my experience leads
to better results yeah I agree and I
think from my perspective nothing is
stronger than truth right like there's
like truth is that rock and for every
every opportunity since this injury and
and and moving forward because you know
post this injury there were a lot of
moments that challenged my truth and and
I've had to recognize them and and
decline to engage in whatever those were
and you wake up at 30 something and
you're missing all of these body parts
right and you're no longer who you were
and you just can't lie to yourself like
you can't you don't have that left hand
you are no longer symmetrical you are no
longer the person you were prior it's
just not true and so owning the truth of
this is the me going forward is also
becomes sort of like the foundation of
all right do I want to do that thing I
don't know is that Who I am is to say
yes to that or agree to that or is it to
decline it and say no and so to your
point of giving up it's not like
honestly I think it's nothing to do with
giving up it's it's actually a super
strong bold powerful move is to just
make a decision based on truth mm-hmm
you know and yeah I don't
that is the power for me anyway mm-hmm I
think the hard part for a lot of people
is is trying to define what that truth
is though sure and and yet I think if
you boil it down though and you look at
yourself naked in the mirror and it's
like well here's what it is somewhere
what makes you happy what makes you sing
what fuels your fire do something small
do something small you know on like by
the hour by the day by the week by the
month and for me go you know in in in
chemo when I was going through all my
treatments for three months for me it
was reading and it was hiking outside
and and I could maybe only hike for ten
minutes on any given one day and then
all sudden it was 15 minutes and then it
was two hours and then you know it was
half a day but I knew that that here's
the thing though to is I knew I needed
that I knew that that was going to just
keep me moving but at some point I
recognized that I was taken advantage of
that too and I wasn't growing I was just
comfortably being like oh I'm gonna hike
every single day and this is gonna solve
everything this is gonna keep me cool
and at some point I had to push out of
that well I think part of the lesson you
know as somebody who hyperactive kid
wants to be outdoors can't sit still you
know in the kitchen you know I would
imagine like you know sort of thriving
on the chaotic you know like environment
of being in a kitchen like all of that
is like that's your that's your like
mana like that's your whew all that
dance and here you just get you just get
sidelined where you have to stop and you
cannot do these things that are part and
parcel of who you are but I would
imagine on some emotional level are
almost like ways of escaping or not
dealing with things that you really need
to work through if you want to become
fully actualized to become a whole
person and you have to have these body
parts removed in order to confront that
and become whole so that you can sit
here today and do the things that you
that you do yeah I think it was
interesting is like that moment
Central Park 2013 with a group called
the Challenged Athletes foundation at a
San Diego the group that kind of got me
involved in triathlon sports and it's
incredible organization oh my gosh they
check them out if you haven't they do
terrific work and a friend is a big
supporter and recommended I check out
the Challenged Athletes foundation and
they invite me to their big fundraiser
event on the East Coast and there's a
fun run in the morning Central Park and
I show up you know kind of you know
t-shirt with my prosthetic on wearing
like skate shoes and skate shorts like I
don't know not really ready to run maybe
a head tension first like kind of like
the sort of legit structured race type
of that kind of thing yeah this is yeah
and this is a fun run but this is what
it is this is the first time that I have
stepped into a room of people's not all
of who have disabilities but into a room
that recognizes the the person with a
disability and says like you're an
amputee and it's not a bad thing it's
like that's how they're just defining
like cool you're 13 years old in your
mail or you know oh you're an amputee
below the elbow cool
you know what sports did you do or it
was like it was just like boom it was
like saying what's your name you know
and I and for me it was that like I had
to give up or I had to throw my hands in
the air and say I give up on this notion
that I can hide and protect the old
Eduardo like when my hair was falling
out going through chemo my sideburns
stayed on for some random reason so I
could wear a beanie
and maybe it looks like red hair you
know and then I whatever I look at
photos of that now and Psyche what were
you thinking you didn't have eyebrows
man yeah but you don't strike me as a
guy who's like trying to hi mean like in
the movie you're like having fun pulling
your hair out with Jen and I was like
wow like that you know written and so to
be fair the rich that was in my home
that was in private like I didn't go out
I didn't you know like I beat other than
my family like I remember I remember
having Passover in Montana and my
grandparents were there and I like I
didn't ask my grandmother but I kind of
just told her how I was considering not
wearing my hat at dinner inside but I
always wear my hat because my head's got
this big divot and I haven't finished
all these surgeries because my surgeries
were put on hold so my head was like
bald no hair big big big open like you
know divot in the back of it really like
disfigured looking and she just looked
at me she was like Eddie we don't love
your head
we love you take the hat off you know
and so forth so when I went to that run
with a challenge at these foundation in
Central Park I gave up the idea that I
needed to hold on to the old me and an
18 year old kid Thomas Kane was my
catalyst he came up and he was like hi
I'm a Thomas sounds like hey I'm Eduardo
and he immediately just zeroes in on my
left hand he's like you gonna run with
that on and he's pointing at my
prosthetic it's like saying hey rich are
we gonna go do a marathon tomorrow or
you bring your backpack you want your
backpack you know like you're not gonna
run with that on and I just had never
considered that I could comfortably take
off my prosthetic in public and just
have my forearm exposed yeah and I did
in that moment I surrendered and I just
owned it I said I need to own whoever I
am right now today like I need to love
this person and you'd be proud of this
person and I need to be an active part
of whoever I am moving forward not stuck
in this old concept of self and how did
that feel to take it off in it I don't
run cash and I was like you hadn't run
without it or you hadn't like you just
never you're always covering it up
I hadn't moved without it being on like
I got into bed and take it off the end
of the day and I go to bed but I hadn't
really done anything active without it
on and it was you ever seen like a you
know an animal frolic sooth it feels
it's like Bing you know I feel free yeah
it was liberating and you know it I
cried it was like man like not I can do
this like I can see I can still run well
how far can I run and so I mean
immediately that night at the fundraiser
you know it's in the Waldorf Astoria
downtown Manhattan 800 people in the
room and someone like nudges me they're
like Eduardo we gonna see you at our
triathlon and I was like yeah and then I
woke up the next morning I was like wait
a minute what's the traffic like you
know no no I had no concept of what I
had just done other than I was just
super jazzed with the freedom to be me
again
yeah and you've gone on and done lots of
stuff with CA off right every year yeah
every year every year do a handful of
travel ons or events and support them in
any way we can you saw I saw I noticed
that you but you somehow strapped like a
big hand paddle on your left forearm to
compensate a little bit like yeah you
make those adjustments yeah for swimming
and I'm still working on my bike
adjustment I do you have a different
sort of attachment to allow you to grip
the handlebar how does that work yeah
it's a imagine like a Pac Man hand you
know so you can just kind of flex it
around the round handlebar mm-hmm they I
mean they're the in there's there's a
lot out there for amputees and then I
mean that's what the challenge a fleet
foundation specifically what they do is
they're like you want to be a Paralympic
snowboarder you want to be a rugby you
know basketball player or a wheelchair
rugby player for kids to you know adults
of all ages so for me I have a hand in a
special carbon-fiber attachment that I
use for biking specific and yeah they
help get those very specialized athletic
advantages to to those people yeah and
so now like lucky me right like now I'm
in a beauty I
get to understand this whole new part of
being human which is living with a
disability or whatever you want to call
it and so then I know it impacts every
part of me like I'll talk about our food
company Montana Mex and just that like
we've always wanted to be a company that
was organic was free of preservatives
was free of colorings was free of any
chemicals was transparent was not you
know doing its best to be a great
contribution to people's lives in the
world around us that's pre-injury
and like you said like you know you
can't rinse transmit something until you
have it and then after my injury I mean
we kept the company open while the whole
company was in ICU with me
brother/sister myself you know we had
one employee still running the show you
know and now Montana Mex represents so
much more in that it's living and
breathing like the before my injury why
we wanted these products to be the
cleanest best they could be for people
and now they still are those but now we
partnered with the Challenged Athletes
foundation put them on our label so now
we get to be like hey we don't just want
this company to succeed from a business
point of view we want this company to
really add value and you know by the end
of the year know that we have executed
our business successfully enough to
actually give back to others not just
from food but help a kid yet that rugby
wheelchair mm-hmm so cool she diverts
some of the revenue towards CAF every
year about five percent in school yeah I
was in the proceeds that's awesome man
what what I saw some video of you with
like the actual button the hand the
Bionic hand hmm do you still have that I
do like I know oh my gosh my how come
you don't wear that I get a drawer full
of them do you I do yeah there's a great
story of my girlfriend my now fiancé
moved in and she discovered the hand
drawer
I was like dad like kicked it closed and
you know I guess I forgot to mention
that the lower drawer to the right
master was the hand room
yeah and what she just stumbled into
some weird circus or something I wasn't
home so she you know but you know I
found that I have friends who are
bilateral amputee so they have
missing both limbs and it really serves
them well to have a prosthetic that is
powered through a motor and that
communicates with sensors to the muscles
in whatever part of the body is affected
and for me I I've had those I've worn
them and I never really progressed far
enough to a place that I was really
excited to use them for me it was just
like it's too slow it doesn't really
work as well as I want it to yeah and I
found that what I'm wearing right now is
a I would say this is your more typical
prosthetic you used to sing upper body
people so there's a hook and it's pulled
and powered by a cable that's attached
to a harness on my shoulder so it's all
body powered movements right
and the beauty pirate beauty of this is
that I can get it wet I can beat it up I
can fix it with what's in my suitcase
yeah it's indestructible and if it
breaks it's not one hundred thousand
dollars to repair yeah and also you're
diversifying your your your dexterity
because that can do things your hand
can't do you have two hands they do the
same thing but that can probably get to
a bunch of stuff your hand yeah is sure
the hook has come in handy yeah I had a
do you know Paul de Gelder uh he's a a
double amputee who survived a shark
attack mmm and I'm on here's got a crazy
story he got attacked by a nine-foot
bull shark in Sydney Harbor and he's
he's the equivalent of like a Australian
Navy SEAL and now he does shark
preservation and his right stories
different than yours but also similar in
the way that he's like using what
happened to empower other people but
also give back to causes and you know
this is cool that that he still goes and
dives with sharks and he's all about
like preserving this animal that
literally almost took his life should
have taken his life right but he had
actual hand and it was amazing that how
you can you know make all the finger
like the level at which this technology
has developed to is really quite
shocking a hundred percent a hundred
percent a freedom it's giving people
yeah now I and so you know I'm 36 years
old and you know
the eye the way that my body now works
with a prosthetic left hand is not how
it's supposed to be I have to put a lot
of pressure into making this hook work
every day right and you know I feel that
my joints and so one day I may shift to
a myoelectric powered hand but for now
it serves me I can beat it up and use it
as a hammer in what has been the most
challenging part of this whole journey
for you like what gets lost in the
narrative that we see out in the world
about you or what do people not
understand and you know something that
that has been difficult for you yeah you
know I I think that there's a certain
level of I keep wanting to say confusion
but it's it's it's it's there's there's
a certain amount of me that feels I owe
everyone and everything so much to the
point that I it's really become a
challenge for me to make sure that I'm
still focused on what I need even though
I've said that so many times just over
the last hour with you in that I mean
how many times when this film like this
film came out of nowhere like let's say
there was no documentary I would you
know gone back to work you know to
worked on the food brand and worked on
the TV show and Eduardo in his life this
documentary kind of came out of nowhere
so I feel like there's a part of me that
anyone who's witnessed this story
watched the film or you know follows
follows me through whatever public
medium just the part they don't see is
the struggle to present continue to
present this life because I'm very proud
to still be alive I'm very grateful and
I feel like sharing this film with
others sharing my story with others is
beneficial to many and I know it I've
heard it I get the feedback every day by
the dozens but then there's a part that
really struggles with saying like I
to her mitt up I want to go find my
retreat and what I'm working on right
now is is not doing the extreme of
either and rather just finding the
balance of how much time do I need to
work on preserving my sense of self in
my own energy and my own compass north
so that I can still be in service of
others
yeah well if you lose sight of that then
you don't have anything to give anyway
none you know no but I can't yeah I can
imagine that the the the demands on you
to show up here and there and they're
probably all cool and sound like fun but
your tank will quickly empty well and
like it's tough man I you know so my dad
passed away last November and the film
has offered me this incredible two-year
time period where I'm being interviewed
with my dad and we're putting together
content for this documentary without
which I would not have liked incredible
incredible pieces of pearls of wisdom in
the form of video or written or editor
or or recorded and so like I'm I'm all
for this process I'm all for sharing
charged I'm all for sharing myself out
there with the world but at the same
time I just I feel like I get a little
lost in I'm I'm hungry for things so
like if I want to go do something I'm
really want to go do it and and it's
still continually very hard feeling
guilty of not giving myself to others
when I'm just like I'm falling apart in
here like I need to be at home I need to
tend to my own tools I need to tend to
my own field here I need to like get
myself in order so I can continue to
give for the rest of my life to others
yeah that's a hard balance yeah but you
live in Montana be harder if you lived
here maybe or like New York or something
you get to go home to your retreat and
take care of yourself I say no a little
bit I do I mean I did 200 for you I did
200 fancy agency telling you you know
what I mean
I do yeah what is what's been the most
kind of interesting or impactful
experience that you've had in sharing
the movie and going around and screening
it the this isn't an example this is a
nonspecific example of what's happened
many times but when when an individual
watch is charged not knowing what it is
but they just it shows up on their feet
or they what they're at a festival and
they just you know the festival uses a
poster of me with a fly rod this
literally happened and a guy and his gal
went in and thought they were going to a
fly-fishing film all right hello you
know not a fly there's some fly-fishing
in there yeah and and yet this guy
raises his hand in the QA and he's like
I'm I'm a veteran I was you know in
Afghanistan and in Iraq and these wars I
have lived in this town my whole life
and nobody is the first time I've ever
said this publicly but I struggle every
single day X Y & Z mm-hmm and I thought
I was going to a fly-fishing film today
and yet through you're through watching
your journey and I am inspired to stand
up right now because I know that my
communities in this room small Film
Festival in Martha's Vineyard
any luck Sean he's like I feel empowered
to share my true self which is I'm this
guy he says his name and I struggle
every day and it feels really great to
say that right now after 15 years that's
it yeah that's that's the first step in
healing that kind of share your story
powerful yeah share your story I think
that's a good place to wrap it up dude
it was pretty good
I'm grateful how do you feel yeah I I'm
inspired to get home playing my garden
my dad well we'll get you home and I
really appreciate your time especially
even more now knowing that that you have
a tricky relationship with coming out
and talking so I don't take it for
granted man it's really powerful and I
know that everybody listening is is is
gonna be really impacted by it so thank
you my pleasure if you want to connect
with Eduardo
you can check out his incredible line of
food products montana mex
montana mex calm right that's it
definitely checkout charged it's all
we've been talking about the last hour
and a half you can I know you can see it
on Amazon and you can see it on Vimeo
are there other places to check it out
Amazon Vimeo iTunes itunes all those
places cool charge the movie and if
people want to connect with you directly
what's the best place for them to do
that or maybe you just don't want them
to you know please say hi either on
instagram at chef eduardo garcia or go
to chef eduardo calm and say hi and i'll
be looking for that new TV show yeah
when it happens to come back and talk to
me about it i will i'm hoping to see you
at a challenge athletes foundation oh I
try so I know body I'm sure you know Bob
Babbitt absolutely yeah I know Bob I
would love to I've been invited in the
past and for whatever reason I haven't
been able to make it but but I would
love to you so I can make that
commitment to you yes right on man peace
nice plants
[Music]